okay um a new game started had some
problems with the board so took took
some seconds to to adjust
this let's see what we get here Kings in
you know grf
grf
the A6 line I think I forgotten most of
[Music]
it what's now
H5 can you allow
to let him let take here I don't know I
forgot simply forgot what's what's
played okay he answered quickly so check
maybe this was still
correct no E5
great I have no
idea
this looks dangerous for me
somehow with Bishop F5 maybe coming
up
okay let's try to win tempy here
maybe now Bishop F5 is a very annoying
move okay we won't play Bishop F5 not
sure what he's up to
uhhuh some strange maneuver with the
queen
okay just Bishop
E2
cile yeah of
course should I play Rook d8 well I
can't spend so much time on
this while threatening Bishop
H6 Bishop H6 King F6 Queen G5
mate I was more expecting Rook
f8 Rook
d8
okay okay the check
now doesn't lead to
much how do I improve here
I'll try
F4 if he plays he plays Bishop F6 I have
Rook
D6 I'm not sure where else he wants to
go as as other words play Queen
E4 okay Rook D6
now well this is the kind of position
where you really wish you would have him
more time
available
h of course I could just take
and put him into some kind of
pin G4 is also interesting takes and
Rook
G1 Maybe this doesn't
work Bishop
F3 I need to make a move at some
point certainly not the
best
check no GES six and Rook D7 Rook Rook
D7 I could have played played anyway
didn't see
it Queen d seven now
maybe as usually I suffer
from time
problems but white pieces um are
protecting each other
nicely p7 hanging
now you could could check here but it's
just to check have King
H2 and also he needs to think of Knight
E6 and Rook E6 Rook G G6 as
well looks um difficult to
defend maybe he doesn't have a defense I
don't see what is I don't see
one at the moment
so so catching up on
time no idea especially Knight E6 is is
um is very difficult to
meet ahuh drop dropping dropping the
bishop
back okay let's let's play this one at
least this wins a
piece with exactly this
line Bishop D7 Rook
E7 I'm a bishop
up I still have um have the activity
here okay now C points
dropping check
check
check now the G Pawn should
decide
yeah black
resigns yeah I think I got a really bad
position in the opening okay I I forgot
all the
lines so um you don't know but um
somehow it's position got much
better not
sure this was
certainly something black should avoid
I'm not
sure um how exactly but this this must
be good for white I've got all the
active pieces G6 is uh is is weak or
almost lost um or very difficult this is
you will need much much more
time
here to to judge it properly